نحن هنا اليوم لنعلن عن اعتقال
دواين كيث ديفيس البالغ من العمر 60 عامًا والمعروف أيضًا باسم
Keepid بتهمة قتل توباك شاكور،
ولم يتم تنشيط هذه القضية حتى عام 2018
حيث ظهرت معلومات إضافية
تتعلق بجريمة القتل هذه التي عادة ما
يمتلكها دواين ديفيس للاعتراف به.
تورطه في التحقيق في جريمة القتل
الذي قدمه
للعديد من وسائل الإعلام المختلفة
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لكم
حيث كانوا في سيارة كاديلاك بيضاء،
أخذ السيد ديفيس المسدس الذي حصل عليه
وقدمه للركاب في
المقعد الخلفي للسيارة
[موسيقى  ]
أعلم أن الكثير من الأشخاص كانوا
يشاهدون وينتظرون
توباك شاكور، فهو أسطورة موسيقية ومنذ فترة
طويلة كان هذا المجتمع وفي جميع أنحاء العالم
يريد العدالة لتوباك،
واليوم نحن نتخذ هذه الخطوة الأولى
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك حسنًا،
لقد كبرنا  لقد كان توباك يعني الكثير
بالنسبة لنا، لقد استمعنا إلى الكثير من موسيقاه،
وكان الأمر محزنًا للغاية، لكنك تعلم في النهاية
أنك تعلم أن الحقيقة ستظهر، وتعلم
في النهاية أن الأمر استغرق 30 عامًا
لحل هذا الموقف أخيرًا
ونأمل أن يرقد بسلام.  و